three billion dollars they've only had
the site up for 13 months this is pretty
extraordinary it's not me it's not
making any money in fact it's burning
cash you know kind of like Amazon used
to this is again this is a bit of a
desperate move by Walmart Walmart a year
and a half ago their market camp was
double that of Amazon now they flipped I
think they're at 230 billion roughly
Walmart's market cap Amazon's 360
billion ish they're just desperate to
catch Amazon or to be more competitive
in the online so this actually chart
illustrates exactly what you're doing
right and and so you're pretty desperate
if you're Walmart they've got about 14
billion annually and online sales which
isn't bad but it's nowhere near what
they thought it would be so jet has been
growing rapidly and they were out
looking for money you know like a lot of
big private companies that are growing
they were out there trying to find
investors to invest in them and and
Walmart came along and offered a pretty
sweet premium is this really one of the
biggest aqua hires in history oh yeah
after an individual yes it is Marc Lori
he started a company so we you know back
in the 2000s diapers.com was a pretty
big name and and eventually it was
acquired by Amazon I think in 2010 for
five hundred and something million he
worked for Amazon for a little while
then he went out on his own and he
started this he started jet comm he's
seen as a bit of a genius a savant if
you will in the online space so I mean
they're not only buying the technology
and the customer relationships in the
website they want him they want Marc and
they're gonna have him for a few years
specific though what is it that this
gentleman can do that Walmart can't do
themselves I think it's you know we've
seen this over and over this goes back
decades where big big companies have
some little niche that they can't fill
and they've tried everything they've
spent a lot of money and he's the guy
who may be able to develop he's got a
theory that most of what's going on with
online shopping especially in the Amazon
space has been higher net worth people
you know upper middle income upper upper
income who will pay a little extra
because they want the product the book
that whatever as soon as possible he's
been really good at going after people
who are willing to wait a little bit
longer but will save a dime or a core
or more on a purchase you know buy
another tube of toothpaste which fits
very much with Walmart which always
wants to add another tube of toothpaste
or another you know shirt if you will to
your order one of the things I always
wonder in a deal like this is this is an
offensive deal or a defensive deal by
that I mean is Walmart trying to
actually transform their company into a
true rival to Amazon or is it simply
trying to stop the hemorrhaging of sales
to Amazon I guess the right answer is
both I mean they're never gonna be
exactly like Amazon you know they're a
bricks and mortar store with stores on
every corner in every city if you will
so what they just want to be more
relevant is the best way to look at if
they want to be more relevant more of a
competitor whether it's with Amazon or
other online retailers